riot police stand at the ready in
central kiev the police presence was
beefed up even as the government
announced it was willing to talk with
the opposition protest organizers are
appealing to the authorities to show
restraint any use of force will trigger
a major public reaction the situation is
very tense and could turn in any moments
we are calling upon law enforcement
officials to restrain from using force
against peaceful demonstrators yep
ravinia approach if you see what you
hear the given stop protesters have been
holding out for days on Kiev's
Independence Square despite freezing
temperatures they vow not to leave until
their demands are met we expect our
government to resign we'll win because
we've been here from the start and we'll
stay till the end we want to be a part
of Europe yes in Europe will help us
very much mayor give me a rope or a
robot up emotion penology pool I do
expect changes for the better Ukraine
will be put on the right path towards
joining the EU usually I'm not one if I
wrestle there are concerns about what
might happen overnight police have
reportedly dismantled some of the
protesters barricades allowing
government offices to reopen opposition
leaders have told protesters to remain
peaceful but to stand their ground